all right
this is the moment Hillside homes in
Shimla fell away during a landslide
rescue workers in the Indian Himalayan
town have pulled at least 15 bodies from
the mud
friends and family are waiting anxiously
during efforts to find at least 12
people trapped under the rubble
the team has been working since Monday
and found bodies yesterday and today we
are hopeful that there are chances of
finding more people
families two of my colleagues and their
families are missing two bodies have
been recovered but we still have hope
that God will perform a miracle and they
will all be safely rescued
at least six worshipers were killed at
this Temple when it collapsed during the
landslide the death toll is expected to
rise
in the shiv temple in Shimla the rescue
operations in full swing we're hopeful
that we will remove the debris from the
temple completely today if the weather
works with us but the chances of finding
anyone alive are very slim
Bridges have collapsed and roads have
been washed away
thousands of people are stranded without
power and communication networks are
disrupted alerts have been issued for
the hardest hit Himachal Pradesh and
uttarakhand states where more rain is
forecast until Friday
the areas experience widespread Monsoon
rain damage last month and recorded
above normal rainfall since June Barbara
angopa Al Jazeera